let's just just get into it
let's just get into the hate crime that
that occurred this weekend
what jake fall oh okay okay okay okay
okay okay
i hate crying
um okay yeah let's get into that i don't
want to talk about it too much though
why it hurts you yeah i mean let's
let's just say i'm very happy nothing
went down that day
oh the day of the barbershop after
seeing that
oh oh yeah i'm just saying when i was
you know when
and was in person with him and there was
a small chance maybe something would
have went down
i thought that in my head right i was
like maybe he's gonna punch me i don't
know
i'm very happy now that that didn't
happen yeah
yeah yeah i think it uh
i think it it it hurts people that he's
got knockout power
yeah because that's that's that's i've
said this many times you can't train
that
you can't just go to the gym and say i'm
working on my knockout power
you could try but that is uh that is a
gift
the fact that he has it go ahead he
really looked like
he knew what the [ __ ] he was doing this
time oh he was super measured
he was very measured like the the
knockout punch came after
two other ones like a combo and it
looked good
like when they played in slo-mo granted
nate like walked into it
yeah but still like the the he was like
a jab
and then and then another jab and then
he came around with the hook
yep and that that overhand right is um
that's a you know
it i'm not i'm not going to say that you
can
really train that like a fast twitch you
know it's not like a left hook where you
like train combinations and the left
hook
comes as a follow-up you know you that
one you cut you have to think about a
little bit
so you know and i guarantee you they
were not training
for nate robinson to do that so that was
purely jake
being able to read in come off the back
foot
and and land it and uh
yeah he i i think it's
i think it's what he should be doing
because as far as an entertainer i feel
maybe he's hit his capacity you know
he's not about to be in tv and film
you know he's he's blackballed from that
[ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean yeah yeah
and but this is how he gets his way back
into it
it's is isn't it crazy how if you have a
feral fan base of teenagers
what you can do you can do anything yeah
i don't even know like i don't even know
what his
fan base i mean these are teenagers now
are they yeah i shouldn't say it's
an older or is it people that like
boxing is it people that like his
his music cause he's really into the
music thing now too
like he's dropping songs all the time
yeah
yeah it's yeah i mean has nate said
anything
since the fighter as he just talked now
he's just still recovering
oh he's i was like scared for that dude
like he's first of all didn't know
what the [ __ ] he was doing it looked
like the fight was
horrible for the first yeah i mean it
was horrible until the knockout
like he would just nate would just come
in and then just
hug him over and over and over and over
again it just looked weird it wasn't
really a fight it was just like what
you know yeah that that's the part where
it was it
i can only say it looked like he'd
never boxed before which blows my mind
because i know he did months of training
and it literally
he just had an adrenaline dump and that
[ __ ] went all out the window
yeah he didn't even try to because even
the way jake came out jake
was he kept backing up because even jake
didn't train
for that what the [ __ ] are you doing
yeah that's really weird
because he's keep hugging me what am i
supposed to do
you know it was bizarre i mean
i mean that that that is one thing i
took away from that
is whoever fights jake next if they
understand pressure at all um that might
be a window into beating him but bruh
he here's so here's my favorite thing is
he's always had a beef with that kid
dylan danis
yeah and dylan said that he'd box him or
whatever and
and daniel cormier said yo
in an mma match i think dylan danis has
a chance with straight up boxing i think
dennis will get
get clapped up by jake and dana's got a
grappler right
yeah he's primarily a wrestler but he
has no stand up and
i think if they end up fighting it's
gonna look so bad on dylan dennis for
all that [ __ ] he talked some years later
to show up and just get
[ __ ] dropped
i just you know it's gonna frustrate it
frustrates me
this kid is gonna have a fight career
that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm thinking it's like who
did he mention in his speech he said
so and so started boxing at 21. deontay
wilder deontay wilder and he was yeah
he's one of the best yeah
i mean he can't really you can't compare
himself to deontay wilder because
deontay wilder has like
he got by on sheer power you know
he had fights where his technical his
technical striking was not there at all
but his
his power is like holy [ __ ] man
you know that youtube channel where they
crush stuff with a with a piston
yeah like that's like what it's like
getting hit by deontay wilder
you know it doesn't matter what you're
made of and if one of those gets through
you're waking up three days later
you know that's a nice little window
sound right there
but yeah so so can you have a
can you have a boxing career without
fighting like a real boxing career would
be fighting
other fighters that are really good but
it kind of seems like jake just wants to
have these
um like really flashy fights with like
celebrities
yeah fighting cans yeah but the thing
about fighting is
uh a lot of fighters get built up that
way
you know it's just not so extravagant
you know people don't pay for
pay-per-views
to watch them fight cans so a lot of
people
pad their careers like that like in mma
there's weird mafia type stuff that goes
on where you get local cards and there's
a gym that's trying to blow up their
homie
so they'll have insane amateur records
you know
25 and 0. okay you know they're picking
anybody to get in the ring with this
going to walmart
yeah you want 50 bucks yeah it's a great
sports island
look at it it's basically bum fights bro
hey man you want to make 150 bucks fight
my buddy right here on saturday
okay you're looking at the boxing gloves
there you box it all
yeah i mean i was thinking about
starting well why don't you come down
you could start
for real you could start racing
initially we could start
with a record
it needs to be a documentary on all
these guys that are owen one that
helped build people's careers so yeah
you know i thought i had a passion for
boxing and then i got dropped by conor
mcgregor and uh
and i actually have a passion for not
being unconscious yeah
yeah turns out i have a passion for
being awake turns out i have a
big passion for for not being
embarrassed on national television
dude when they were pulling the camera
back and nate's just like on the ground
unconscious and the
[ __ ] announcer goes man we really
gotta stop
letting these unexperienced people in
the ring i was like yeah oh
yeah so bad it made the announcer
question the whole [ __ ] event
yeah dude jesus christ dude steph
curry's wife coming on being like i
don't
i don't see a knockout i see someone
trying something new and that's cool
and and they you know
who would want to live life with regrets
and it's like
this dude had this amazing tweet where
he said rich people
need to stop treating boxing like it's
just a hobby it's like
it's not it's not it's not crochet it's
not skydiving
it's it's permanent damage like that's
what i'm saying
like there's a very real chance nate
could have lasting damage from that
yeah no nate is he's gonna be more
likely to pee himself a little bit in
his later years
because of that punch man yeah yeah
no but it's like a new hobby it's just
you know it's it's cool to not have
regrets
yeah yeah let me tell you something nate
nate robinson will get
regrets dude it's that fight yeah yeah
exactly no but you have to fail
sometimes to learn new
things and boom boom boom we're talking
brain
[Laughter]
i see someone you know uh falling
upwards let's say
[Laughter]
yeah when you run it he's gonna be
falling all over himself in about
20 years bro